the raiders play their final preseason
game this sunday right here on channel 8
they're going to be playing the niner
sports director chris matthews joins us
with more on this uh final preparation
right yeah thank you very much christian
yeah this is the final dress rehearsal
before the regular season kicks off and
games then count this is the one that
kind of the last chance here for coaches
to get a good look at a player that
might be sitting on the fence kind of a
game situation type deal here so the
raiders will be cutting their roster
from 80 down to 53 by next tuesday so
kind of makes you wonder who's sitting
on that fence one thing we do know not
many starters will be playing this
sunday in that final preseason game and
there is a reason for that
i think the risk
versus the you know very little reward
of of seeing a guy in in preseason
uh and everyone's got a different
opinion on that we just felt like uh we
want our team to be fresh when we open
the season
uh
we felt like we've gotten good practices
uh not only the you know with the rams
but also the practice we've had out here
and and just you know different
philosophy i guess then some people have
it some don't we just want to make sure
their team is is fresh and healthy when
we do start the 17 game season i'm
definitely getting time this sunday i
plan on playing and i'm just looking
forward to being out there with my
teammates
all right so diablo expects to play
don't expect quarterbacks derek carr and
marcus mariota to see any time as you
mentioned the risk reward just really
isn't worth it hey and don't forget
you'll be able to watch that game right
here on channel eight we are your
network home for the raiders sunday one
o'clock it's the raiders versus the
niners right here on channel eight
should be a great hey this is the 40th
time they played in exhibition games but
this is the first since 2011.
christian